the void is the latest 80s movie to come
out today because everyone who is a kid
in the 80s has now grown up and they can
make movies so we're seeing a lot of 80s
inspired entertainment lately and the
void is about a police officer in a very
small town who stumbles across someone
who at first he just thinks is a drunk
kid on the road when he takes him to a
hospital that's when shit gets really
weird members of a violent cult start to
surround the building the power goes out
and there's a really odd creature
growing out of someone's eyeballs so
that's kind of fucked up and man did I
enjoy it the void is a throwback to
classic 80s body horror movies like the
thing with fantastic prosthetic creature
and makeup effects this movie has very
little actual CGI in it there's a green
screen moment towards the end for the
most part this is a make-up lover's
dream the prosthetics in this movie are
the star the creatures that appear in
this movie are incredible it was such a
delight for me to see because I'm a huge
fan of 80s horror a lot of people view
the 80s as the time period work for
repeat because there was so many chance
takers a lot of people were taking a lot
of real risks with horror and making
weird as shit movies and not caring
today we get a lot of independent horror
where things are going in a very cool
direction with movies like the babadook
and things like that but with this movie
this is a clear throwback to that era
where you just threw a bunch of scared
characters in a building and gave them
limited weaponry and very little
information about what's going on
because they're all really just grasping
at straws they don't know what this cult
outside is how it relates to the strange
entities that are blossoming out of dead
bodies they don't understand the weird
religious teachings of some certain
characters in this movie I won't spoil
anything but it all kind of connects in
a very strange way and you go through
this experience with them because they
know as little about it as you and so
when these characters discover things or
they're just really really terrified you
feel that way for them because you also
have no idea what the hell is going on
that's also one of the movies faults
this film is a little ambiguous
there are certain answers that are given
to you and you can kind of grasp some
things and be like okay I get we're
saying there but for the most part I
would say this film is really just an
excuse to throwback to 80s horror and do
some really fun stuff with makeup and
prosthetics and if that is the case they
succeeded very well I would have liked
more well-rounded characters though I
don't need that in a movie like this
like I said I'm not going to look at
this movie and be like well this just
has to be a character piece with an
amazing screenplay and everything has to
be perfect oh my god it's not perfect I
understand that these movies are purely
made for fun and to add some really
epically gory effects and they did that
extremely well I still would have liked
the film to have more well rounded
characters because the film does ask you
to care quite a bit towards the end
specifically in the lead character and
his wife possibly ex-wife they don't
really make that clear there's some
scenes where they really want you to get
into their relationship and it just
feels like it's drawn a little thin also
the ending was a little lackluster for
me it leaves you wondering it leaves you
kind of hanging and I wanted a little
bit more I just wanted kind of more of a
punch when this film had such an
interesting setup and a lot of puzzle
pieces that could really make a very
cool hole it does feel a little
scattered once the end credits hit and
that was a disappointment but as a
horror film and as someone who really
loves these types of movies this was a
lot of fun I'm going to give the void of
B it's going to be playing in very
select theaters very soon and I'm not
sure about the whole VOD schedule
because I got to see this pretty early
with a private screen or link from the
studio so I'm hoping that this can be
more readily available for you guys soon
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuff in eyes
[Music]